[Music]
first it goal at the three
play fake feel throw
top touchdown Jeremy record with the
touchdown catch his second of the day
both touchdown pass of the day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
fist rushing touchdown of the season for
Justin field
yeah well Mike Brown comes up to the
edge on a blitz and fields makes him
miss cuts back on Bharati and goes right
back into the end zone 40 nothing and
now going into the a 53-yard pass for
the score - Brandon play-action pass
Justin fields is looking towards KJ Hill
the entire way 16 yards of the last play
this time for the end zone - touchdown -
Chris a lob a second to the game for the
sophomore from California and I think
it's safe to say that the floodgates my
friend are open comment as a runner
watch out off first down play fake
cop touchdown again I love a twenty nine
yards muscle memory de stuff
[Applause]
for testing fields
first and goal at the for opening drive
of the second half for the Bucks and
fields looking at the end zone
touchdown JK Dobbins now he picks up a
receiving touchdown to go along with his
rushing touchdown and 194 yards rushing
watch where Fields puts the ball low
into the outside right on the body of JK
Dobbins it's perfect throw
[Applause]
how about strong hands by the freshmen
Wilson out of Austin Texas
gobbets back in the game
[Applause]
Juston field 51 yards watch the eyes of
the FAU players they're all going with
Dobbins on the offenses right fields
with a big hole and then you see that
explosiveness as he takes off for a
touchdown down at the IU 37 playful feel
sexy
[Music]
chris'll have a touchdown [ __ ] 37
yards fields knows he's got a lob a wide
open and he throws a great ball in the
back of the endzone and a lob a is able
to just run under it
what up into boy Adam left goads you
like that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report